nelle puntate precedenti di residenti va
c'è dobbiamo passare in mezzo al
cantiere wow dritti nelle fogne aspetti
che c'è un coccodrillo gigante lo faccio
fuori poi scendi ok non mi ha preso per
niente vabbè ma tu ecco bagnate a gas
io non posso continuare questo gameplay
ve lo dico non esplodono non esplodono
mamma mia ragazzi che disastro niente di
quello che faccio va come vorrei
perfetta storia della mia vita adesso
sono muore adesso ma a me ne vado
mi ha creato perfettamente la strada per
andare via serve una doccia civilmente
sbloccato beh sinceramente se dovessi
trovare una doccia per carità
dopo 60 anni di tentativi finalmente
l'umbrella corporation certo bellissima
e umbrella corporation comunque mi è
sempre piaciuta tranne per gli zombie
però allora siamo ufficialmente entrati
nella breve che sarà gigantesca immagino
legge per messico ma allegra meno male
sapevo che all'ombrello avrei trovato un
po d'allegria le tracce finiscono qua
vediamo ciao spero siano morti tutti
sono buttato una granata nel senso
sprecata ecco infatti questo non so se è
morto non si capisce ma che volete olet
gold che ho detto a sono dall'altra
parte perfetto stato un caso che ecco
questo mi sto pie colpi di brutto quando
ti trovo cioè non è che mi stava bene fa
avere un sacco quando prendo lo unisco
all'altro
speriamo di trovarlo salve cipe detto a
livello 2
andiamo diretta più che figata che
figata sta roba qua perché area quest
area east andiamo west arabo avesse
sarebbe questo no fortuna che solo
inglese c'è il livello 4 addirittura
calice un livello 2
quindi devo andare nell'area est a
trovare un braccialetto parlare ovest
wow
sono proprio contento di questa cosa non
so se si vede una eco quella mi serve
quella mi serve tantissimo
porca vacca qualcosa mi dice che
lanciafiamme e stavolta mi tornerà
si le ho proposto presentimento con dio
mio quanto fatto bene il suo gioco
no ci sono gli zombie pianta che è uno
zombie piantina scusa se dargli popolo
sa se gli dai fuoco schiattano quasi
subito almeno si liberano per terra che
non è male tra morti proprio conto come
in pokémon di tipo erba perfetto ma
posso uscire nel mentre tutto questo
serve solo la tessera metri che ora c'è
una piantina in mezzo a tutte le piante
non avrei mai detto siete ma comunque
vanno giù facilmente col lanciafiamme
almeno quello beh una scala figo che
stiamo andando esattamente ma non ci
sono piantine spero permesso salve mappa
laboratorio area est
questo a 2 esce là dove esce ma parco
demonio porco porco da dove è uscito sto
qua posso lancia fiamma rlo mi mancavi
pezzente schifoso era da un po che non
ti vedevo non so se col lanciafiamme
servito qualcosa in realtà
porca vacca salve stia lì ok qua siamo
al primo punto la mia quindi cosini
trattino quadrati fretta ok cosini mio
dio
ok fatto drug testing l'ha bloccato che
hanno sbloccato la macchina indirizzo
vado a mettere le cose nella macchina
veloce perfetto che sia stata abbastanza
veloce ma cosa mettiamo il caso mamma è
un vecchio un bikini camerata pensavano
già fatto anche il professor layton una
volta però uno show fatto importante
quello non ho capito bene come
contenitore soluzione che ora che a
tornare tutto sotto laboratorio e e joey
signori 6 anni ci abbiamo messo vai
c'è tutto adesso in prosa
ora con questa roba che mi fa e devo
andare poi nella roba della serra e
riesco a prendere quella chiave macello
meno male che ho capito subito cosa
dovevo fare strano per me cioè perché io
capisco le cose a metà sempre detto er
viscida signore signori vaporizzazione
le erbe o anni per fare sta roba
dai
ha fatto 800 giri spero che schiattino
pure quei quei zombie piante almeno
cascata la chiava attenzione potendo
capitolo la chiave e non so se giulia
che dentro un po schietto e allora mi sa
che muoio cioè senso non mi picchiate
perché non vorrei mai farmi del male sai
non sono uno che va in contro i pericoli
di solito nella mia vita non lo faccio
mai mi è mai successo capito questa
chiave quali devo andare nell'ala ovest
giusto che ho messo una vita per
prenderlo a studiare bene ala ovest
secondo me al ponte non ci arrivo
neanche per sbaglio ma che non succede
niente fa che non succeda niente perché
non succeda niente perché non succeda
niente ma succede
eccolo lì parka vaccamorta io parlo e
poi è sempre quello è tieni che lo tieni
tu nel tuo regalo
speriamo abbia fatto qualcosa sul serio
mi hai dato vera lo scienziato giusto
volevo dire una cagata però penso di
aver capito il non male e la lo
scienziato dei video
sei una di loro e non sai coinvolta in
tutto questo si ma tutto questo non
sarebbe dovuto accadere allora racconta
fin dall'inizio
non avrete così facilmente
dar
[Musica]
mio zio william che cosa hai fatto tu
hai creato questo mostro abbiamo creato
il virus ma non immaginava non trovare
scuse in ragazzi ecco mi sa che è morta
non è ancora morta paga no vabbè
non potevo andare semplicemente fuori
dalle balle no dovevo farmi affrontare
godzilla ok grazie cara
quindi devo combattere io sto a fare qua
perché non possiamo farlo scappare fallo
tu porca vacca ti pare ma seriamente
questo potrebbe essere un problema come
obiettivo cioè ancora torna da da beh
non sarà così semplice
c'è un po di occhi sta a fare qua però
risparmiato dei colpi per l'arma della
forte perché per queste esigenze
puoi farti beccare sulla schiena che
palle traggano di scaricare maresca per
farlo sulla schiena sono problemi ma
riesce un altra roba eccolo lì
la capi di così non sapevo che fare
ragazzi sto veramente questo sparando di
tutto impossibile
le franco guarda che stai esagerando qua
gli ho sparato tutti i proiettili che ho
risparmiato in tutto il gioco di quella
forte che è questa qua tutti me ne sono
rimasti quattro in realtà non gli aveva
mai usati proprio perché volevo ho detto
vabbè serviranno in un momento di
bisogno tipo questo sono serviti sono
stato bravo cioè strano non sono io non
sia mai neanche morto una volta forma ci
puoi rimanere anche poi fai tu se mi
fido sentire riguardo prima non so se
promettimi che distruggerà il campione
del cipe è una prova
ci penserò le spire ti fidi di quella
stronza
che cosa vorresti dire
lei non è delle birre è un approccio
east non vuole vendere che il virus
andrà al miglior offerente di stronzate
spero sia così o se il virus finisse
nelle mani sbagliate
quindi la fine ad a e affini cioè una
mercenaria sul serio cioè sul serio in
realtà non lo so però quasi sicuramente
così alla fine ci tradisce lei
wow sta roba era meglio non saperla
forza ha quindi non era io pensavo se il
boss finale a una certa vedete un po
troppo forte
eccola giovanna c'è questa ai diritti di
amministratore potrà entrare là dentro
stavo giusto pensando a te
siamo una bella squadra ma una domanda
pip il mip in tv culo testa sempre quel
napoli darci dei napoletani
sì ma prima ho incontrato ha detto dice
che non sai delle pie
io perché non vuoi darmi il cammino
ahia ho provato e credevo di poter
rischiare
mi dispiace speravo davvero non finisse
così pandora il vero però solo una
pedina per te faccio solo il mio lavoro
e io il mio abbassa quella cazzo di arma
sei in arresto dammi subito il campione
lione o ti farai male ma crollando tu
ecco
lo sparo e allora se ne sei capace boom
subito a no che saranno
va da
è cascato il virus
resiste
spazzola
lasciami tutti d'accordo con me lo
merito
sì ma state cadendo tutti e due è quello
il fatto buona fortuna a lione
[Musica]
mi piace lieto fine se non ti muovi però
morì anche tu però va bene ma comunque
poteva tirar su dai resterà il doppio si
prova di servizio per cadere mentre si è
mosso vabbè e tempismo
vabbè mi ha sbloccato il centro quindi
posso andare giù dicendo che fugge dal
laboratorio andate qua no
tutto questo mentre sono morente dai
facciamo da meno mettiamoci almeno in
sesto per ragazzi sta saltando da tutto
in aria se mi consenta non è neanche
colpa mia
però ragazzi deve aprire a 9 minuti un
minuto l'ho perso solo per andar giù
ascensore
sarà mica claire per questo se ci fa
questa qua basta per provare tutto
arriva come è arrivata qua waster
dartene in fretta
[Applauso]
non aspettate mettete in salvo
porca vacca desplat 8 st c'è tutto
adesso tutto adesso
ok vai vai veloce ma devo fare tutto
questo in tempo in realtà di qualsiasi
cosa mi si para davanti devo farlo fuori
vai col fucile a pompa i cattiverie
proprio eccoli lì no va preso pensavo
non ci arrivasse top scusato subito sì
non mi metterà se mamma mia che casino
oppure no vabbè sto male pure lui
questo ci fa come è arrivato qua e alla
stazione di polizia arrivato qua quello
come è possibile allora senso è figura
lancia mi normale per una volta e mi va
di culo via via
18 18 bene per una volta è andata bene
ora però devi muoverti pecorari va
ovunque effetto strano non c'è nessuno
che combiniamo prendi prendi cos'è sta
roba connettore elettrico che ancora
devo fare roba che pensavo fossi sul
finale wow
hanno forse lo devo mettere subito mano
eccolo qua si infatti connettore ti
connetti lo connetti le tirate york
e quello di pre è di nuovo lui è un tool
era un tubo io ormai ho qualsiasi cosa
esplode penso sia quel tipo che esce dal
muro h ormai come incubo di notte mi
sveglio paura che sfonda il muro mi
ritrovo ovunque anche nel frigo eccolo
guardalo no ti prego dimmi che non è lui
il boss finale perché ne vado ma non è
anche i colpi della pistola proprio
tantissima cioè no veramente pochi quei
tipo morire non muore mai
non ci crea tempo pure a tempo ma tu
stai scherzando
ma cosa non ho idea di come farlo fuori
non so è immortale
volevo semplicemente resistere non so no
vabbè ma non va giù è impossibile
ok è successo qualcosa ditemi che è
finito perché non lo reggo più è
difficilissimo dimmi che non ha due fasi
per
devo coro che ada e ancora viva
lanciarazzi anticarro no
piatta o al vero pensavo mi avesse
ucciso con l'ultima botta detto no sono
morto alla fine che residenti paul
finiscono tutti dove tu hai una specie
di lanciarazzi potentissimo dove si
spacchi il nemico in una botta sola e
che ho detto no e lanciarazzi finale
dove spacchi i nemici con una botta sola
79 lanciata finali europee herzog e
lorbek invece non ce l'ho fatta
non ci credo mai la facciamo a uscire
quindi ad ancora viva che poi c'è un
treno che passa a caso
glia bravo lyon mi sei piaciuto è stato
proprio bravo
amen stato molto difficile
brutta la votano
ottieni
incredibile mi ma se c'è l'eco e donne
soprattutto se ignota
ma per uscire è il bisogno dell'accesso
a livello 3 io l'avrei tenuta per non si
sa mai
quella ei
[Musica]
è fatta te l'avevo detto no
alla fine claire e là dentro il vagone
col gatto
il lieto fine quello bello che lo beh
lei si meritava tutto non l'altra
ragazzi ci sono poche mosse non è vero
però è d'aiuto sì forse no
sì dai
buskers comunque spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto spero che la serie vi sia
piaciuta questa era il resident i volti
molto figo molto figo veramente bello
ben fatto
mi è piaciuto piaciuto tutto tutto
tranne il boss finale che stato un dito
nell'anno però ci sta quindi ragazzi
come al solito se vi è piaciuto lasciate
un commento vi piace anche vari social
che come nevi dal fratello descrizione
se non siete ancora i siti iscrivetevi e
noi ci rivediamo ad un prossimo video
hanno un prossimo zombie ci risiamo
beh ragazzi
[Musica]